comme depuis le début du confinement
christine haxaire est l'unique salarié à
venir s'occuper du poney club de l'ucp à
montigny le bretonneux
aidé par sa famille qui logent sur place
elle dédie sa journée aux équidés non
s'embête pas du tout pendant le
confinement on a plutôt des journées
encore plus chargé qu'avant puisque bas
les et qui démontre tous les jours tous
les matins à 8h30 il faut être là pour
les nourrir les mettre en liberté
remettent de la paille prob vider la
paille salle on continue l'entretien au
travail des équidés qui sont présents
sur site donc on les montons les longes
on a récupéré donc de l'herbe dans la
ferme du mas n'est donc on a pu créer
des petits paddock où on arrive à mettre
tous les poneys à tour de rôle à partir
de 11h jusqu'à 16h donc ça leur fait
voilà des belles journées pour permettre
aux équidés de se dégourdir la ferme du
mané qui est fermée au public a mis à
disposition les jardins inoccupé depuis
le 14 mars
le poney club n'a plus aucune activité
et les pertes financières commencent à
se faire ressentir
on n'est pas encore concerné par toutes
ces aides là il faut savoir qu'on est
une association dont on fait pas
toujours partie des bonnes cases pour
avoir toutes les aides je pense que les
choses vont s'affiner au fur et à mesure
des décrets qui passe pour les aides
gouvernementales et on espère bien sûr
pouvoir toucher des aides pour nous
permettre de continuer à perdurer
l'activité
cette directrice espère néanmoins une
réouverture rapide du site pour
permettre de reprendre les activités et
le retour des adhérents tout en
respectant les gestes barrières sur les
sports il semble que ce soit plutôt mime
et qu'on ait des informations de toute
façon on suivra les décisions
gouvernementales et les décisions
municipales puisque effectivement le
maire a aussi son droit de regard sur
l'activité et on appliquera bien sûr
tout ce qui sera demandé par le
gouvernement on espère bien sûr pouvoir
reprendre au plus vite avec toutes les
précautions sanitaires nécessaires
en attendant la reprise d'activité pour
l'ucp à montigny les poneys continueront
une forme d'écho pâturages dans la ferme
du manet